revenons maintenant aux fêtes de noël et
à la bonne chère de plus en plus de
produits de luxe sont vendus à des prix
très bas en supermarché c'est le cas du
caviar on vous en a déjà parlé aussi du
sommet or depuis 1926 une petite
entreprise de montreuil en
seine-saint-denis continuent de fumer le
saumon à l'ancienne halle en produit
peut il est plus cher mais il aussi bien
meilleure philippe barnérias fernando
valverde le saumon symbole de la
connaissance et de la sagesse depuis les
gaulois la france est la gardienne d'une
authentique tradition somalienne
c'est à montreuil en ile-de-france
qu'elle est honorée dans toutes les
règles de l'art à six depuis 1926 la
maison ça fasse se situe aux antipodes
du saumon industriel ici la devise a le
goût de la simplicité savoir prendre le
temps pour faire le meilleur oublier
l'automatisation du 20e siècle
les petites mains tiennent tête aux
cerveaux de la nouvelle technologie le
principe est simple une personne à
chaque étape pour un contrôle renforcé
de la qualité du produit
le travail manuel permet ainsi à chaque
stade de la fabrication d'éliminer tous
les défauts toilettage salage et des
pillages autrement dit retirer les
arrête un travail minutieux auxquelles
doit répondre une main d'oeuvre
qualifiée
qualifiés ou bon marché du personnel
asiatiques
c'est parce qu'il s'avère que le
personnel asiatique très très bien avec
beaucoup de soin à votre conscience
professionnelle
c'est donc en fonction de l'entreprise
perpétue la tradition jusque dans ces
fumoirs qui date de 1926 et qui sentent
bon le chêne et le hêtre le fin du fin
de cette préparation revient à ces
saumons ont trié sur le volet est
suspendue au dessus d'un foyer d'où leur
nom de saumon à la ficelle les papilles
gustatives sont également mises à
contribution une mauvaise réaction et
c'est la poubelle résultats la société
sa phase ne produit que 1 % du marché
mais c'est celui que l'on déguste en
première classe air france le prix
incontournable de la qualité 250 francs
le kilo
le free est un indicateur très important
de la qualité on ne peut pas faire des
bonds seulement qg à bas prix c'est pas
possible
les produits haut de gamme réservé
jusqu'alors aux professionnels mais
depuis un an la société a ouvert son
comptoir aux particuliers qui déjà
manifeste des signes d'impatience